Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Vincent Racaniello, who is a virology
professor at Columbia University and also host of
the podcast this week in Virology. It's so great
to have you on today. I appreciate it.
Speaker 7: My pleasure. Glad you could
make it after all that rain yesterday.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I saw the videos. It's something
else. Listen, I'll just jump into some things
because there are maybe some specific things that
that are new ground for my audience that I think
might be interesting to talk about. And I think
it'll it'll open up a broader discussion with
something like the idea that there is a period
of time during which you can be incubating this
virus. In other words, you have been infected.
You don't yet have symptoms. You would not yet
test positive if you were to be tested. What is
actually happening during that period of time?
Is it that there are some virus particles in you
but they've not established themselves in your
system like what is taking place at that point?
Speaker 7: So let's think when you
get infected, you typically inhaling
droplets that have been produced by someone
else. Right? They're infected. They're droplets
have virus. You inhale them into your nose.
Typically, they go into the cells lining your
nose and further back, which we call the nasal
pharynx, and the viruses then attach to cells.
It's not easy to do that. That's why a lot of
viruses have to get in you to start an infection.
But the viruses attach to cells, they're taken
into the cells and then they begin to multiply.
And in the very first hours, it's very low
levels. The viruses are in maybe a few cells.
They're beginning to multiply. You can't really
detected by PCR, but then you go above a threshold
where those cells produce virus. The virus infects
neighboring cells and it goes on and on. Maybe it
takes about 20 hours for a cycle to complete
in a cell. So after a few days, you are now at
the point where you would test positive by PCR.
So in that interval that you're interested in,
the virus is multiplying your your immune system
is beginning to detect it. You have the earliest
immune system, which is called innate
immunity, can detect what's going on there.
And in fact, most infections are stopped very
early on before they progress any further.
But then if the innate immune system doesn't
work and part of that is interferons,
which you may have heard about, which block
virus infections, in many ways, if the innate
immune system doesn't work, the virus keeps
multiplying. And then we have activation of
other immune systems which include antibodies and
t cells. And then it becomes a race to see if the
virus can outpace it. And then after a certain
number of days, maybe five days on average,
you might then feel symptoms. You might get
a scratchy throat, you might get a headache,
you might get a fever and so forth, which might
prompt you to go get tested. And bingo, there
you go. You get a PCR test and you're positive.
Speaker 1: I have friends who have gotten a bunch
of the Abbott home tests. And for example, a
friend had a birthday party with ten people
last week. And of course, everyone had to
be vaccinated. But he also tested everybody
on the way in. And his belief was if there was
a negative from someone who was in this state
you and I just described, the virus has entered
their body, but they are not yet testing positive
that it's OK because they are almost certainly
not contagious at that point. Is is that actually
our best assessment of one's level of of how
contagious you are during that intervening period?
Speaker 7: Yes, the PCR tests are very sensitive.
So if they are picking up nucleic acid, you have a
good amount of viral multiplication. And if you're
negative on this test and you go to an affair for
a couple of hours, certainly in the time of that,
you're not going to change from noninfectious to
being infectious. So if you're negative, I would
say you have 24 hour window before you might even
start shedding virus and infecting others.
Speaker 1: When it comes to the conversation
of variants, I've read a number of pieces
that say that evolutionarily the way that
there is selection pressure on these variants,
the idea of a significantly more deadly variant
becoming dominant is not particularly likely.
I know that there's a lot in there about level
of infectivity versus the deadly nature and a
lot of things to unpack. But let's start with,
is it true that it is unlikely that
a much more deadly strain would
become dominant? If so, why? If not, why not?
Speaker 7: When we look at all the viral outbreaks
in humans over the years, for the most part,
viruses do not become more deadly. If anything,
over a long period, they become less deadly.
They become better adapted to their hosts.
And I'm talking many, many years maybe. Hundreds
of years in time, and so there's no there's no
evolutionary reason why a virus would become more
deadly because it would kill its host faster and
it would be less likely to transmit and transmit.
Transmission, of course, is the raison d'être for
a virus. So the variants are certainly arising
because of some kind of selection pressure. Right.
We think part of it is immunity in the
population. We didn't see these variants until
late in 2020 when a lot of people globally had
already been infected or vaccinated and had some
kind of immunity. So antibodies can certainly put
pressure on a virus so that you would select the
virus that is slightly different and can evade the
antibody happens with influenza virus every year.
And there are probably other selection mechanisms
that we don't know about because these variants
have a lot of different changes. So I think in
the end, what we can say about the variants,
they're selected probably mainly because of immune
pressure. They're not likely to be more deadly,
even though there's some studies here in there
that suggest that they're not very well done,
they're not very well controlled. I think the
main issue is, is immunity and escape from it.
Speaker 1: And over a period of time, would we or
let me put it a different way, there is already a
trial going on with a modified MRI and a vaccine
tailored to more recent variants. I don't know
the exact timeline of when that may become the
one that you get when you go to CVS or Walgreens
or whatever the case may be. Is it likely
that, like the flu shot, we would need to be
tailoring the vaccine to the most recent variants?
Speaker 7: It's certainly possible now with
influenza that can happen every year
or two, right. We tailor a new vaccine
and we have so much experience with influenza
that we know when antibody levels drop
below a certain point in people we know that
correlates with them getting more severe disease.
We don't have that information yet for
sars-cov-2. We don't know what antibody levels
or protective. We don't know how low you can go
and still be protected from disease. Right now,
the vaccines protect against severe disease and
death, even though antibody levels are declining.
So it's not clear if when we would need to change
the vaccine. I think we have to wait and see
if more and more vaccinated people this is the
key. Do fully vaccinated people start to get
more sick? Do they get severe disease?
Do they die? When we reach that point,
then we talk about changing the virus vaccine.
Speaker 1: Earlier on, there was the idea
that was much repeated. I guess we would
call it a belief that the two dose regimen
of either the Fizer or Moderna vaccine
would likely be good for at least a year.
There were discussions of two to three years, etc.
More recently, there has been the data from Israel
that shows that the antibody levels, although,
as you say, we don't know exactly what that means
in the real world, but antibody levels seem to
start declining after eight months. There's the
idea maybe after six months one would get a third
dose. I've also read some doctors say the third
dose will almost certainly be the last one. At
this point. It seems to me we really just don't
know. We really just can't say three is going
to be it. What is it that we need to be looking
at to really get an answer to that question?
Speaker 7: So one thing we have to understand
is that with every human viral vaccine, you
get vaccinated six to eight months later,
your antibody levels decline. It's the
natural process. There's nothing new about
sars-cov-2 vaccines and antibodies declining,
although people are making it out to be a big
deal. OK, they are declining. And with that,
there has been a push for boosters. What's
not declining, though, is protection against
severe disease and death that remains robust.
So the antibody level decline, you may get
infected even if you're fully vaccinated,
but it happens with just about every other
human viral vaccine that we know about.
But you don't get serious disease. That's how
we tested these vaccines to prevent covid of
any kind. Now we're getting mild covid even after
fully vaccinated. And so the key for a booster.
So I think the booster idea is somewhat flawed
because the idea is to push antibody levels up
again, but they're going to decline in six to
eight months. So are we going to go every year
and give people a booster? I don't think
that's a good public health strategy, frankly.
The key is, do we still prevent severe disease
and death? So far we are doing that. And as long
as that protection remains strong, then I don't
think we need to have a booster. And to think
that it would be the last one will. There's simply
no data to suggest that I. I think that would be
great if it were yeah, but we simply don't know
Speaker 1: when it comes to the seasonality of
this, when we were going into last fall, there
was, generally speaking, a consensus that we
were going to see a big increase. And the the
explanations vary depending on what what you
looked at. Part of it was similar explanation with
influenza, that as it gets colder, people spend
more time inside and that that's going to going to
increase transmission. We were not yet vaccinating
at that time. This fall, we seem to be seeing at
least the growth of cases slow down. It's not yet
declining, but if we're six to eight weeks after
where Europe is, maybe we are starting to get to a
peak. So maybe maybe we won't see that increase
into fall and winter, although maybe we will.
What's our best assessment right now as to
the seasonality of this and what is actually
the source of that? What what generates that?
Speaker 7: So we really don't know how seasonal
covid is, right. Because it's brand new. And when
you have a pandemic that trumps all seasonality
effects of sampling. In 2009, the pandemic
influenza virus emerged in August, which is
totally weird because they usually come out in the
winter. But when there's a pandemic, most people
are not immune. So the virus can spread even
though it's the wrong season. So that's what
we're seeing with sars-cov-2. Now, there are
other coronaviruses that infect us. They cause
common colds. There are four different ones. They
are seasonal and it's likely just by extension,
that sars-cov-2 will be seasonal as well.
Although still we're in this pandemic phase where
seasonality gets trumped by simply if you have a
lot of susceptible people around which we still
do, the virus will reproduce whenever it wants to.
Speaker 1: What is the actual mechanism for this
seasonality? Is it as simple as the temperature
forces people indoors and increases spread?
Speaker 7: Well, that's a good question, because,
you know, seasonality is different for different
viruses. In the heyday of polio in the in the
world, that was one that spread in the summer,
very warm weather when kids were out playing
and so forth. But influenza is in the winter
and seasonal in temperate climates. And we
think that's because of the low temperature
allows the virus to remain infectious longer
and the low humidity keeps those droplets
that you exhale keep keeps them very small because
in humid conditions, they take on water, they
drop to the ground more quickly. When it's dry,
they can travel farther and infect people. But
we don't know much about that. For most other
viruses, it's a really tough topic to understand.
Speaker 1: So I know how to frame my
next question. Have you seen the mask
efficacy study from Bangladeshi data? I have not.
You have to tell me. So I'll my understanding of
the Bangladeshi study on mask efficacy is that
for older cohorts, there was definitively reduced
transmission from mask wearing, although the
statistical significance of the reduction seemed
to be lower. The younger the cohort you looked at,
there may be other confounding factors there. So,
you know, I think that the devil is probably in
the details. What's our best assessment right now
of the impact of masks on reducing spread? Because
it's become very politicized and controversial and
maybe the science doesn't suggest it should be.
Speaker 7: Yeah, so the masking is tough because
it's hard to do a good study. Right. You would
love to be able to take a group of people
with masks and without and challenge them with
viruses. See mask what? We just can't do that.
So we have to use surrogates. And so I think
the best estimate for for covid is that
when worn properly and that's a big if because not
everyone wears them properly. And I see more and
more people just having them below their nose
because they're they're so used to it. Maybe
it's up 60 percent of transmission. And it makes
sense because the droplets that carry the virus,
they get caught up in the mask material. It's not
the virus that gets trapped. It's the droplets
carrying the virus. So if you wear them properly,
so there are no gaps, maybe 60 percent, it's not
going to be 100 percent ever. And we know that in
many countries where they use masks quite often in
respiratory viruses, and it does make an impact.
So in my view is that it's an easy thing to do.
It's not too much of an inconvenience. I'm used
to it by now, so I don't really see the issue.
Speaker 1: Let's pause our conversation with host
of This Week in Virology, Vincent Racaniello,
there on the podcast, the TV show, the radio
show. The full conversation is going to be
posted to our YouTube channel at YouTube
dotcom slash The David Pakman Show.